also tonight our cyber safe parent
report we're going to take a look at how
a network of thousands of law
enforcement officers are working behind
the scenes 24-7 their goal to help keep
your kids safe from predators
a cyber safe parent inquired about how
exactly local law enforcement keeps our
children safe from predators it is
called the internet crimes against
children task force our primary goal is
to prevent the exploitation of children
our primary emphasis that we look into
is those people who are trying to
you know victimize children through what
we call child sexual abuse material the
icac task force is headed up by metro
police working with the fbi henderson pd
north las vegas pd and the ag's office
we do follow up through our various
investigative techniques the national
center for missing and exploited
children sends along crucial cyber tips
about anyone possessing or
redistributing these exploitive images
we go out we do follow up we do search
warrants we take them into custody in
the more extreme cases it is taken to
the federal level you're looking at some
pretty serious felonies and some pretty
serious time how bad is this issue
yeah you know that's a great question
it's actually it's really bad it's worse
than most people would think in an
effort to protect kids the icac task
force takes an aggressive and proactive
approach we call them predator
operations very similar to what some of
the viewers have probably seen catch a
predator used to be on tv
similar to that minus the media and we
don't care so much about the shaming
aspect of it as just apprehending these
people the suspect will initiate contact
with who they think is a child online
and there is an agreement to meet they
show up to the meat spot with whatever
it is that they said they were going to
bring they instead find a bunch of cops
and fbi agents who arrest them these are
some of the worst predators we refer to
it as shooting fish in a barrel with how
many of these terrible predators are out
there 60 to 70 percent of the criminals
that are viewing this kind of material
are also hands-on offenders so it's very
rewarding to know that not only did we
you know put this person behind bars but
we saved anywhere from one or two to
potentially dozens of future victims
from having to deal with the horror of
of reliving that scenario
now this is only the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to our cyber safe parent
coverage we have much more on this and
many other subjects that are so very
important for parents at eight newsnow
dot com just click on the cyber safe
parent tab